[Music]
Of course, there are deficiencies, the conditions are very clear, it
is not possible to be prepared for such a big disaster.
Because we, our
citizens, do not worry, we
can never allow our citizens to stay on the streets, especially
apart from the statements made from the headquarters of Afad,
do not give the provocateurs the opportunity to
unite today.  it's time for solidarity
[Music]
[Music] He
went to Hüseyin makin
[Music]
bring the thing with him at the Style
[Applause] we are
praying anyway, there is nothing we can do, there is nothing we can do, if
we see it, I will tear
it apart somehow, maybe I
will take it out with my hands, but we cannot see it.
As I said we pray